OK! Hello everyone we are once
again in YouTube's studios,
and I'm joined by Jordy Delage.
We're going to discussed about a topic that he knows particularly well,
and that is quite rarely covered in most aikido discussions.
It's the philosophical and religious aspects of Ueshiba's approach.
I'll let Jordy introduce himself,
and explain why he's someone who can contribute to the debate,
more so than a lot of us, and myself in particular.
Thanks for the introduction,
I'm not sure to what extent I can bring more to the debate than others,
but it's true that I studied
Japanese culture and language at university so I have an academic background,
regarding the history of japan,
and that one of my specialties during those college years
is Japanese religion.
Shinto, Buddhism,
and to some extent, Omoto-kyo - Ueshiba's religion -.
Through the light of an academic study of history and religion,
I wanted to understand how Ueshiba's mind worked
and what were the messages behind the esoteric speech
that were at the core of his teachings of Aikido.
To do that one had to understand the historical and religious context,
as well as the outline of Omoto.
I studied Omoto in some details,
but as an atheist, I didn't have much incentive to get into the details of its cosmogony.
However, there are trends that emerge from Omoto,
which are very original and very specific
to this religion,
and which are very interesting, in my opinion, to shed light on the philosophy of Ueshiba.
Perhaps, in some way, some form of humanism, when placed in the context of time.
The philosophy in Japanese schools at the beginning of the 20th century was not really permeated with humanism.
That's it, I hope I can contribute to the debate a bit.
The question that comes right away is that people start Aikido for a number of reasons.
Would you say that you started Aikido because you had an interest for this message,
not religious, but philosophical.
I didn't start Aikido because of any message it might have contained.
I started Aikido because I found myself by chance in an Aikido club.
A friend told me: "You should come and try, it's fun".
So I went and I took a few classes.
It made me move a bit, I was 15 years old, I wasn't at peace with myself,
so during my teenage angst, Aikido was a good was to find some sense of balance.
I continued, but not because religious reasons
because it wasn't the style of my school or my club.
To put things into context, it was the school of Andre Cognard's, who was a student of Kobayashi Hirokazu in France.
Kobayashi Hirokazu was someone who developed Aikido with a certain ethical sense,
and with a large importance put on conflict resolution,
relationships between people, and so on.
It's interesting because you started Aikido a bit by chance,
then you must have leaned about the philosophical message,
and then it influenced you choice in terms of university courses.
Yes, the way it unfolded it interesting
because I was lucky to find a teacher
who was someone quite simple.
I believe he was 3rd dan when I started with him,
but he was a very kind individual,
who didn't talk much, but who often said the right thing to make you think.
For me, it seemed consistent with the image I had of oriental religions,
in the way it encouraged people to reflect upon themselves, etc.
It was a bit silly to think that because he wasn't religious at all,
but I had this image, so I quickly became interested in the philosophy of aikido.
After a year or two, I started reading books,
some good ones, some bad ones, especially some bad ones, because there are a lot of bad books.
Some of those books gave me a false image of Aikido,
- it's the case for a lot of people -
The majority of practitioners has the expunged image,
- in a way, the official image  -
of "The Invincible Warrior" by John Stevens,
who wrote a lot of very bad books about Aikido.
And then and when I decided to come to Japan.
I had been practicing for a little over four years when I took the decision,
so it was before going to university, after
after getting my baccalaureate.
I thought I'd better study Japanese language rather than Japanese religion
so I mostly focused on that during the two or three months before going.
I went to Japan, I did Aikido at the Aikikai,
so I left my previous school,
and I didn't do much philosophy when I was at the Aikikai because the place isn't really suited to that.
I was really busy during my year in Japan,
I was learning Japanese, I was practicing a lot,
- when you practice a lot, you're often tired, so you don't have a lot of energy or willpower to do much else -
but after a year I realized that I had missed a few things.
I wasn't idle, I went to Tanabe,
I visited all the great temples
in Ueshiba's home region.
Buddhist religion, in particular, has always interested me from a cultural point of view,
but nothing specific to the philosophy of Aikido or Ueshiba.
In the objective of being able to come back to Japan and to be able to spend more time,
and maybe this time, to catch up on what I had missed during my first year,
I decided to study Japanese at university.
That's where my decision came from.
When i saw that they had a religion class that was well put together,
I thought it would be a good opportunity
for me to acquire the keys
that I knew I would need for a more personal study, later on, in Japan.
I didn't want to risk to look into religion before having the methodological tools to do it
because I know how easy it is to fall in some certain tendencies...
Knowing myself, I didn't want to risk falling into that.
Your grid of reading was an academic one.
Yes, I absolutely wanted this academic methodology.
I did not have it, I knew I needed it, so that;s what I went to get at university.
So I guess that you studied Shinto...
Shinto, Buddhism, and as my personal project, Omoto, on which I wrote a paper.
Talking about Omoto, was there anything about neo-religion in that curriculum?
The main course was mostly on the history of religions in Japan,
religious syncretism,
The relationship of the Japanese people towards religion through history,
which is especially interesting in the 19th and 20th centuries, especially the 20th century.
a little bit a few short on
Then a few classes on neo-religions obviously,
on New Age religions, in a way,
of which Omoto is one of the first.
Omoto is one of the first New age religions in Japan.
There were several attempts at about the same time but it's the first one that really took off.
They ended up with tens of thousands
of followers
at a time when
Japan was in search for religion.
The Meiji era s fascinating, it's my favorite period in Japan's history,
precisely because it was the time of the big change, the big upheavals, when people were lost,
when New Age religions appear precisely to fill in the lack of spirituality, that kind of things...
So precisely, Shinto was obviously very well implanted, the syncretism with the
Buddhism,
so there wasn't an absence of religion,
it was in everyday life, even though its importance is quite relative in Japan,
but could you explain what those neo-religions brought to the table,
especially Omoto,
compared to that Shinto base from which
they started?
There are two axes.
There is the axis that what I'm not going
not develop because I think that
everyone can understand that basically, the old religions do not provide answers to new problems.
You find this problem in all religions all over the world
Every time there are big revolutions, New Age religions appear
because they bring answers that other religions does not bring, from a spiritual point of view.
But questions that are totally concrete.
Absolutely, very often, on very concrete questions.
For example, the Japanese religions never really considered the opening towards foreigners.
On the other hand, Omoto worked on universalism,
which is something that was really quite new in Japanese logic.
Then there is a specificity of Japanese religions,
which is much more true for Shinto than for Buddhism,
but it'is also true for Buddhism,
it's that there is little interventionism in life of the average person.
[Japanese] religion defines a number of behaviors, like all religions,
but it doesn't give absolute keys on the
way of living one's life.
In my opinion, it's one of the major interests of the study of
the relationships between Buddhism and what we call today "bushido",
because bushido defines a number of
behaviors
that are consistent with some religious principles,
but it doesn't call upon superior or absolute ideals that would come from an Almighty God.
It's a system that built itself on totally practical aspects of the life of the warriors of that time.
Therefore,
Buddhism and Shintoism don't bring this absolute power,
and this absolute truth.
It's fascinating because even today in today's Japan,
we see the consequences of that.
I didn't come up with that, I read it in a book,
perhaps René Sieffert, or another expert of Japan, said:
"The Japanese are born Shinto, get married Christian"
- I was going to say Catholic, but precisely not Catholic, Christian -
"and die Buddhists."
That's incredibly true.
Ceremonies for children birth are Shinto ceremonies,
they get married by fake Christian priests,
on stages with cultural elements issued the
Christendom,
and when they die, those are Buddhist ceremonies.
What's fascinating is that
even today, researchers still wonder about that,
sociologists still wonder about that,
the Japanese themselves still wonder about that,
"Are Japanese people religious?"
The question comes up regularly, all the newspapers that talk about japan regularly do an article on this subject,
and is everyone always come to the same conclusion, saying:
"No, not really..."
When we talk about religion, we talk about faith.
Yes, we speak about faith. Are they religious in the Western sense of the term? In the sense of monotheist religions.
Precisely, because in the West, we distinguish "religious" or "devout" or "from a religious culture".
Yes.
They are very devout in the sense that when they build a house, they will have a Shinto ceremony,
so they are devoted, but there isn't necessarily any faith behind that.
It's more like folklore.
there is a quote by Musashi that I like and that goes:
"Revere the gods but don;t count on them."
It's extremely pragmatic, it's really a warrior's sentence.
It means that even if they don't exist, it won't hurt to do it...
It's Pascal's wager...
But if they exist, better not anger them.
I think that Japanese sociology
- with or without religion, -
is built upon a large number of pragmatic facts,
contrary to what happened in the West until the end of the 19th century.
Alright, there are a number of things that need explaining here...
How about we deal with it in the chronological order?
Ueshiba Morihei was raised in a Buddhist context.
Could you briefly go over this?
Yes, I think that we shave to start by that.
I was born at the end of the 19th century,
in the midst of the Meiji revolution.
The fighting is over.
The difficult transition period is over but,
it's a full blown Westernization period.
They take all of the Western technologies and they implement them in Japan.
He was born in that kind of Japan.
However, one should keep in mind that Tokyo is ultramodern for the time,
but Tanabe, not at all.
Tanabe hasn't seen the beginning of the industrial revolution before 1905-1910.
It came due to the war...
The Russo-Japanese war...
Yes, the Russo-Japanese war, and then the First World War,
which are periods that boost the economy,
and which allow technology to reach the countryside.
But before that, Japan has so much to catching up to do that their money is focused on building a modern Tokyo.
A little bit in the South too,
and also in Kyushu, due to the connections with foreigners that happened in the past.
But it was limited to a small number of entry points.
Tanabe, even today, is hard to reach,
so you have to imagine what it was a hundred years ago, it is in the middle of nowhere.
Around 6 or 7 years old, he starts learning Shingon Buddhism.
I need to point out that Tanabe, Wakayama, and that whole region is one of the two great religious centers  of Japan.
There is Izumo, in the South, which is even harder to get to,
and there is Wakayama, which has a lot of temples.
It's a beautiful region, which is even today relatively little urbanized.
Even more so at the time.
Japanese religion being linked, on the one hand, to one's ancestors, and on the other hand, to nature,
a region like Wakayama, with its mountains and its temples, its waterfall, etc.
- the famous waterfalls that we see on Ueshiba's photos, -
is quite conductive to spiritual and religious development.
He followed those teachings until he is about 20 years old, I think.
He did a bit of Zen too in the meantime.
He also received a title of transmission within the sect.
So we are talking about a very serious curriculum.
Very serious
Practically professional.
From that point, he could have decided to become a monk.
Besides, it seems to me that in some writings about the youth of Ueshiba,
he is already described as a mystic at age 25.
When you start at 6 or 7 years old
and that you get a monks' scroll of
complete transmission at 20,
the framework of Buddhism, and especially that of Shingon, which is
an esoteric and very complicated kind of Buddhism on top of that,
- it's much more complicated than Zen -
It will necessarily stay with him all his life.
That I think that his switch from Shinto to Omoto later on can be explained by that journey.
After that, he got other experiences.
By nature, Shinto doesn't have a teacher-disciple transmission like Buddhism.
It's much more tenuous.
Moreover, Shinto was very different from one region to the other, even at the time.
So the only truly structured religion was Buddhism
You spoke about syncretism between the two,
from the moment he had this curriculum in
Buddhism,
were there some aspects that were, mutually exclusive,
or was it all integrated then?
That's a difficult question that I couldn't answer with a lot of confidence,
because on the surface, Shinto and Buddhism are totally merged.
There are temples that are completely merged,
for the Buddhists, the Shinto gods are emanations of the Buddhas,
So it's really inextricable.
But based on what I read,
from a certain level of esoterism,
- notably in Shingon, and perhaps in others -
- there are many esoteric Buddhisms -
they must get to a point where the
their theorizing, their theology,
allows to extract Buddhism from Shinto,
I'm not sure I could answer without being religious myself.
So when we talk about Ueshiba studying Buddhism and Shinto, we can consider that it was Shinto/Buddhism,
that there was no transition from one to the other.
No, there was no transition at all, it's one and same thing.
Then when he traveled away from Wakayama,
he went to Tokyo, etc.
he may have lost some ties with his Buddhist upbringing,
- he already chose not to pursue this vocation -
He went up to the city and came to Tokyo.
To put it in the context I was explaining earlier,
it's equivalent to someone today who comes from the middle of nowhere and moves to the capital.
That's it but to the power of 1000.
I think that the first time he went to Tokyo, he wanted to settle as...
A stationery.
Yes, a stationary, but it didn't go very well...
It didn't go very well but we must keep in mind how hard it must have been for someone form the countryside.
It must also have been extremely competitive.
To put it in context once again,
All the samurai who were employed 30 years before,
- 7% of the population -
found themselves unemployed.
They placed a few of them within...
Administration.
Yes, they placed some of them into administration.
but they didn't want put too much because of the small revolts that occurred before,
and the goal was to change the whole system, so they thought that if they placed samurai everywhere,
they would end up with families that were more powerful than others, etc
They had to cross that out and suppress the system of casts.
So for it to work form a social point of view,
the redneck had to be able to become the new samurai.
Otherwise, it wouldn't work.
They didn't leave the door wide open, like what they did after WWII,
but they did slightly open the doors.
That said, the mother of Ueshiba came from a samurai family,
she was issued from Aizu, the Takeda family.
I'm not sure because it sees that Ueshiba had to borrow a kamon from someone to be accepted by Takeda.
So to what extend was Ueshiba really from a samurai family,
or which type of samurai family,
because hierarchy goes from very low to very high.
I don't even know whether the lower classes samurai had a kamon or not.
It's likely that they had
but once again, even by the end of the Edo era
the system is already a little bit in the process of disintegration,
there hasn't been any fighting for more than 200 years...
If they has really been from Aizu,
after the defeat they suffered, it's obvious that their status would have been undermined.
Yes, but that would have gotten erased by the Meiji revolution.
He could have said: "I'll take back my title, and let;s not talk about the details"
I think it would have worked.
The problem is to understand that even if it had been the case,
the small samurai families were relatively poor,
and had much lower living standard than the merchants, who were far richer,
even compared to some farmers, who had managed to become rich then.
Precisely, Ueshiba's father was a land owner.
Very well considered, at least on paper.
So those who were landowners and rich
were well considered,
those who were landowners and poor were not.
Merchants, who should have been under the farmers in the caste system
used their money to be well considered.
When the whole system got dismantled,
though having samurai origins could always be useful,
it didn't have true reasons to be.
So it's logical that Ueshiba went to town to start a stationary.
It's exactly what the government of the time wanted for its society.
They wanted entrepreneurs to compete in the Western logic.
It didn't not work for Ueshiba, though we can suspect that his father helped him a lot,
because his father had some money.
At that time, he had already mingled in martial arts,
he went to Tokyo and discovered many things,
- it should really contextualized like this -
Ueshiba, son of a small land owner from the countryside,
moves to Tokyo,
starts his business, fails,
he had already done some martial arts at that time,
there is a rise - not yet of nationalism at the time -
but of a desire from Japan to have...
What year are we there, to give a time frame?
It's the beginning of the 20th century,
Ueshiba was born in 1883,
1903?
Just before the Russo-Japanese war.
Just before the Russo-Japanese, precisely.
At that time, Japan wants to became the equal of the Western powers,
but Russia gets in the way,
it's an excellent opportunity to explain
to the West than the 20 to 30 years of modernization that Japan undertook,
brought them to a level were they can compete with Western powers.
And against all odds, it worked.
And against all odds, it worked,
and what's truly remarkable is,
- I jump a bit in time, because we'll cover that later -
it's the fact that Deguchi Nao predicted...
Yes, she predicted it!
the Russo-Japanese war before it broke out,
she predicted the victory of Japan,
that's what gave a lot of credibility...
It gave her a lot of credibility...
And she lost it afterwards when she got mistaken...
Yes, just after, she gets it wrong...
On the colonization...
Yes, she predicts the failure of the Japanese invasion in China,
but it turned out to be a success.
She lost some credibility.
Later, she predicted WWII
she predicts the war with the US and the absolute defeat of Japan,
so she was right once again.
That said,
the world at the time was filled with people who made predictions
and there are necessarily some of them who can be right sometimes.
Who guess right, of course,
we never mention all those who were wrong.
Exactly, it since she hasn't always been right, one can question things.
That's the context.
The young Ueshiba enrolls in the army because it;s a good opportunity.
He failed his entry into commercial, consumerist, Western life in Tokyo,
so another way to be useful to his country would be...
We're dealing with someone who's in search of himself.
Yes.
He's trying to find his place in society,
and the war was a legitimate cause.
Just like 90% of the Japanese of the time.
That;s why the historical contextualization is really very important.
The complete upheaval that there has been in the Japanese society,
the destruction of the caste system,
the race for technological and economical development in order to catch up with the West,
out of a fear of being colonized.
- it was the specialty of the West -
Especially since they had threatened to do it several times.
They had threatened Japan,
they had made them sign a number of less than advantageous treaties,
and strengthened by the victory against Russia,
Japan could renegotiate a number of treaties.
In a more egalitarian relationship,
that no other nation in Asia could enjoy.
Absolutely.
It interesting to look at it this way.
It's also perhaps what gave birth to the first nationalistic sentiments:
"Japan does everything right..."
Clearly, especially since that when the had to find out the reasons behind their success against the Russians,
they though: "What could it be?"
"It must be bushido!"
Yes.
It's funny since it's just after -
some 20 years after -
the fact that the government totally disowned any culture linked to bushido.
During the Meiji revolution they even got to the point of not
re-hiring the samurai in the army of conscripts
because they wanted to completely cut off everything that had to do with this warrior past.
It's also quite ironic to see that today we
consider
- a lot of people consider -
martial arts [budo] as arts for combat,
even though there hadn't been any war for 250 years
and that when it became necessary to build a strong army...
They didn't call upon those guys!
They didn't take those guys.
We can always go back further in time, obviously these are martial arts,
but it seems to me pretty difficult to justify the teaching
of a really combative fighting spirit in the martial arts in this context,
and I think that it must also have been difficult to justify form Ueshiba's point of view.
He's in that context,
- and something else that is quite remarkable -
He starts learning juken, the bayonet,
he's apparently becoming a good fighter on the battlefield.
The discussion that we had with Bennett not long ago
- I don't know whether it'll be published before or after this interview -
shows us that Ueshiba was perhaps not a great master of bayonet...
At least not the Japanese techniques...
Right, technically speaking.
But we know that in spite of that, he was pretty efficient on the battlefield.
But again, a Western one.
It's a Western art.
He fought with a riffle, not with a sword
so we never heard of Ueshiba's skills with a sword on a battlefield.
He did carried a sword though, but no.
It's quite interesting to...
to thin about this context of how much Japan wanted to be more Western than the Westerners.
Just like foreigners who come to Japan today want to be more Japanese than the Japanese...
At the time, Japanese wanted to be more Western than the Westerners,
and they were pretty successful.
It might be this tendency to push to much in that direction
that created an inverse sentiment, a return to nationalism, to the roots, etc.
I think it influenced a lot Ueshiba's thinking a few years later.